Good morning John, it is September 19th.
And it is also Wednesday.
This song is about Katherine Green.
That was the wrong chord.
I've come across a lot of ten dollar bills in my time
In swimming pools and taxi seats and ATMs and on the beach
Finding free money is something I can do
But when I think about my luck I only think of you
Yeah sure when I go downtown I find the perfect parking spot
Ok I guess the right answers on my tests a lot
And yeah when I fell out of that cypress tree I didn't die
But you my girl are the luck of my life yeah you my girl are the luck of my life
Once we met this guy on the way to a punk rock show
And we helped with some boxes
Even though we didn't know that he was with the band
And he got us in free
But the only reason I felt lucky is you were there with me
Yeah sure that light turned green before I hit the break
Ok no one notices half of the mistakes I make
And yeah when I ate that rat poison I didn't die
But you my girl are the luck of my life
Yeah you my girl are the luck of my life
Yeah ten thousand people watch me online each week
Ok no one has ever had a cooler job than me
But one day one girl said that she'd be my wife
And that day was the luckiest of my life
Yeah you my girl are the luck of my life
Happy Anniversary, Katherine.
John, I'll see you tomorrow.